let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right um so cbs news correspondent
ed o'keefe reports that joe biden has
called a lid
on the whole week until thursday night
not the next debate
uh we're not going to see him again
apparently until the debate o'keefe says
joe biden uh still has not answered any
questions about the new york post's
multiple reports about biden's son
hunter and the laptop
not just one multiple laptops apparently
this guy's got
it's got to be difficult to lose one
laptop but this guy has lost
laptops all across the globe he's just
he's been globe trotting
and like johnny appleseed or something
just just dispersing laptops apparently
um and uh and but we haven't really
heard anything from
from uh from biden officially on this
denying it if it was if these uh
now we've heard from some people on the
left and people in the media trying to
run cover for them
and some other elected democrats saying
this is all a russian
this is a this is a russian
misinformation campaign well if that was
the case if they were
if these were just fabricated made up
emails
uh fabricated at a whole cloth this is
nothing but but fantasy and fiction
then biden will come out right away and
say this is completely made up this is
crazy
and if there was reason to think that it
was a the russians were involved then
biden would say that too
but he hasn't he hasn't said anything
and
and he has been asked now in fairness to
me he hasn't been asked that much so
it's not like he's
he's had his feet to the fire but he has
been asked a couple times in fact he
stopped for a milkshake over the weekend
and the first question he was asked is
uh what flavor milkshake he got
because this is the kind of media we
have but after that
he was asked about the emails and here's
how that one
chalker but i wanted to get him black
and white
wave it away wave the question away i
don't have time to talk about this
ask me something important like what i'm
going to have for lunch after the uh or
you know what what am i going to have
for breakfast tomorrow we'll talk about
that
what am i going to put in my omelette
tomorrow why don't you ask me that what
are you asking me about this
for so it's that easy if you're a
democrat it's that easy but now this
means that biden
will have to whatever excuse he's going
to come up with for this
he's going to have to give it for the
first time
live at the debate now true the
moderator is not going to press him on
it but
trump will talk about it so biden will
have to say
something he's not going to be able to
get through the whole debate not even
acknowledging this
he's going to have to give some kind of
answer
and whatever the excuse is he's gonna be
debuting that excuse
that talking point live on national tv
with an aggressive opponent standing
right next to him
this seems to me like an incredibly
foolish political strategy now
you know who am i to give advice
especially to a democrat but
it seems to me if these emails are real
which there's no reason to think they
aren't
bet if i'm in the binding camp what i'm
going to do is i'm going to come out
like right now
and say yes they're real uh you know
come up with everest whatever excuse you
want hunter biden comes out gives a
tearful apology
uh and and you you come up with it
doesn't matter just some bs
you could come up with whatever bs
excuse you want especially because you
know the media is going to be on your
side
and then but the point is you just you
you get it all out there now
and then you got two weeks before the
election and you hope that people forget
about it by then which they probably
will because
as i always talk about people forget
about everything that would be the smart
strategy
but they're not going with that instead
they're they're dragging this out and
they're going to have joe biden
address it directly at the debate for
the first time
um all right well
what another reason to tune in should be
fun to watch
number two um and i say this by the way
i say this as someone who
um i think the emails
are of course important and relevant and
they potentially
expose corruption so
they they matter they actually do matter
but i i'm skeptical about how much
they'll matter in the minds of the
average
voter and i'm and i'm also i'm
i'm a little bit worried and i could be
wrong i always take the pessimistic
approach as you know so
um i'm not looking for the silver lining
i'm looking for the dark cloud
in you know that's that the silver
lining is encompassing
so from the dark cloud approach
i i do worry whether with two weeks left
in the
campaign is this the best closing
argument
should this be the final argument
against biden should it be something
focused around hunter biden his
his loser scumbag son
even though it involves joe biden too
uh allegedly is it is it best for this
to be the closing argument or
what we have been hearing from the trump
campaign which is that joe biden is a
trojan horse for the far left we talk
about the riots we talk about all this
kind of stuff anti-police everything
else
now yeah you could do both but sort of
one thing or the other has to be your
primary focus especially with only two
weeks left
i tend to still think that the most
important thing the thing is to be most
persuasive
persuasive to voters and that's the
easiest to understand
is the fact that he's a trojan horse for
the far left which is also true
by the way and important so
i'm not really sure number two um there
was another protest over the weekend of
course this one i think in boston
and here's a protester anti-trump
protester apparently pretending to eat
a heart a bleeding heart
just watch
i'm on fire
better chaos
make america great
god
super happy
okay so this is either mental illness or
drug abuse
or demonic possession or perhaps a
combination of all three
maybe we don't have to choose we joke
about trump derangement syndrome and how
trump has
literally driven the left insane but the
truth is that these people
were already insane they were driven
insane uh many of them from their own
sense of entitlement and their own
narcissism that's what's driven them
insane
but what that means is they simply
cannot psychologically handle being in a
position
where things are not going exactly as
they like and want
and that's where donald trump comes in
because they hate him so much
and they were so sure that he shouldn't
be president and then he became
president
and they they couldn't handle it that's
why the classic
the classic clip of the the woman on her
knees screaming no at the sky
what is that it's just she she cannot
deal with
this and this is what we're seeing from
the left
so entitled so narcissistic they
psychologi they have a psychological
break
when something happens that they really
really don't want to happen
number three democratic senator chris
coons on cnn on sunday is the
latest to come out and explicitly
threaten to add seats to the court
the supreme court speaking of having a
psychological break because things are
happening that you don't want
if he doesn't get his way in the barrett
confirmation fight this is this is the
threat that he's making listen
if barrett is confirmed and democrats
win back the senate
would you vote to expand the number of
justices on the supreme court if it came
up for a vote
is that something you'd be in favor of
well jake like joe biden
i'm not a fan of expanding the court but
we have a few weeks here to see
whether there are four republicans who
will step back from this precipice
it is president trump who has pressed
for this nominee
so he can have a key vote to overturn
the affordable care act in the middle
of a pandemic it is the republican
majority that's responsible for racing
forward
with this extreme unqualified nominee
unqualified because of her extreme
judicial
philosophy and that's who should be
bearing the brunt at the ballot box
in this election that they're doing this
to get someone on the court
just in time a week after the election
to take away critical health care
protections
from a majority of americans we need to
focus on that so you oppose them if we
happen to be in the fact pattern where
we have a president biden
we'll have to look at what the right
steps are to rebalance our federal
judiciary
so your mind is open about adding
justices to the supreme court yes or no
just
your mind is open yes your mind's open
okay you know
i think one of the most shocking things
about 2020 probably the most shocking
thing
of everything is that this confirmation
fight has has and maybe i'm speaking too
soon because the final vote is until
thursday i guess but uh so we still have
a few days for this to change but as of
right now
this confirmation fight has been really
easy and smooth
we we were all particularly predicting a
knock down
drag out fight to the death kind of
situation
and it hasn't been that yeah they've
gone after amy cody barrett but just
with the standard stuff
handmaid's tale comparisons that sort of
thing so just really standard leftist
talking points nothing too you know
nothing too serious
and that's been it um know a big part of
that is because amy coney barrett is
that bulletproof
um of a of a of a nominee
but also it makes me again going with
the pessimistic angle uh
it it it makes you a little suspicious
and then you realize well
why is it going so smooth because i
think the democrats they're being coy
about it but they
they fully intend to go with the uh
to to pack the court i think they fully
intend to do that now
and that's why they're cutting their
losses here and they're saying well we
can't stop it anyway
there's no sense in coming off like
psychotic lunatics any more than we
already do just in our day-to-day lives
so we're just gonna let this kind of
happen
because we know what we're gonna do when
we're in power
all right number four many reports in
the media claiming that
the owner of the redskins well the the
then redskins
told the cheerleading coach
that he has to keep the cheerleaders
skinny and with big breasts only he
didn't say breasts
uh but but dan signer the owner said
that
that uh they have to be skinny and you
know and and that way
or or the cheerleader coach will be
killed
now i think we can assume the or i'll
kill you
part of it was not meant to be taken
literally
and assuming that the rest isn't much of
a controversy right
of course you want the professional
cheerleaders to be skinny and busty i
mean as opposed to what
but the the interesting thing is that
the media headlines are about this
alleged comment from daniel snyder
about him body shaming or whatever but
it comes as part of a larger report
that among other things the redskins
allegedly produced lewd videos of the
cheerleaders
and the videos were created and
disseminated to someone
without the cheerleaders knowledge now
apparently the other claim is that the
women may have
signed a contract giving the team
permission to make whatever kind of
video they wanted so they might not have
a legal
leg to stand on in any kind of lawsuit
um
but even so it's it's interesting to me
that
that that's the story and you would
think that would be the headlines
instead the media is making making
headlines about
um about mean comments from daniel
snyder
the mean words are the headline not the
potential alleged softcore porn video
made
allegedly without the permission of the
women involved so you see where
priorities the media go
okay number five finally um i've just
been i've been biting time waiting for
this this is my favorite this is my
favorite story of the year perhaps
a rapper who goes by the name nuke
bizzle
uh recently released a song called edd
where he bragged about getting rich off
of fraudulent unemployment claims
and he has now been arrested for filing
fraudulent unemployment
claims he's accused specifically of
access device fraud
aggravated identity theft and interstate
transportation of stolen property
faces up to 22 years in prison after
being apparently mailed
92 debit cards loaded with collectively
over a million dollars in benefits that
he then turned around and
used uh i think at least half of it
uh so he he did all this now now this is
you can you can almost see where he's
coming from a little bit because rappers
routinely brag in their music
about committing crimes so i think nuke
bizzle figured well
i mean they brag about it so why can't i
but the problem is
that he bragged very specifically about
a particular crime
that's easily proven see if you're gonna
do this as a rapper and brag about
committing crimes you have to be you
have to be a lot more vague than that
like you can say that you've killed a
bunch of people but if there's a
specific
open investigation into a murder and you
confess to it
by name in a rap song
and even film yourself dancing around
with a murder weapon probably you're
gonna go to jail
and that was the mistake kind of subtle
but that was the mistake that nuke
bizzle made
anyway i know you're hoping and praying
right now that i'll play the song for
you and uh your prayers will be answered
without further ado here is the great
artist nuke bizzle
with his masterpiece and he like he
he paid dearly for this song so i think
we should all enjoy it and appreciate
his sacrifice
uh but here's his masterpiece edd listen
created your card now has been activated
you know 2020 the unbelievable vd
[Music]
[Music]
i be so happy
[Music]
now i i think the main guy you just
heard there uh full disclosure was not
nuke bizzle
the youtube video says it's nuke bizzle
featuring fat whizza
a rapper named fat wizard now i don't
want to engage in stereotypes or body
shaming myself but i'm assuming that the
first gentleman rapping in the video
was fat whizza given that he's well
fat but in any case notice the lyrics
what what what 12 or 13 of them i could
actually understand he says
you got to sell cocaine i can just file
a claim
i'm doing the stuff that you can't i'm
smart and you ain't
yes smart well that's one word for it
fat wizard
wouldn't be the word i'd choose but
things are open for interpretation i
suppose
i do want to say though credit where
it's due there was one part of this
video
um that that i saw it and i thought it
was legitimately
positive so here i will look at the
silver lining uh and i think there's one
part of the song that had a great
message
and i wanted to show that to you also
watch this you got the name and number
and i got the edit we can put something
together
i got the alien cat they have a show man
to be here to the better baby
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's talking about killing
people is of course he's of course
bragging about felony fraud fine fine
fine
but in the video he's actually um you
can't see this if you're listening to
the audio podcast but it's it's it's not
reflected in the lyrics but
in the video he's wrapping uh in one
scene with a toothbrush
he's got his toothbrush in the bathroom
and he's kind of like brushing his teeth
and he's also wrapping
at the same time just like i do every
morning in fact when i'm brushing my
teeth
and i think that's a really positive
message about oral hygiene
that's the main headline for me as a
hopeless
optimist i see that and i think okay
that's what this is really about these
guys defrauded unemployment
in order to be able to fund and shoot
this
psa for oral hygiene and maybe this will
start a trend
and all the rappers will try to one-up
each other by showing off their
elaborate dental care routines it's
possible
next thing you know like drake is gonna
have a video where he's guzzling
listerine out of a
golden chalice i mean who knows it could
be a positive development
that and that's what i'm going to take
from this i in this case i will
i will see the positive so uh best of
luck to
nuke bizzle um i would hate to think
that he goes to jail for 22 years
and we are deprived of
his music it'd be hard for me to even go
on in a situation like that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content